[Applause]
or fur against Kevin law that's the
matchup that's worked well for Boston
and hooker quickly stores on hills
ootball moving here from Cleveland
Jane's on the attack stops Brown goes
for the fake town and won the ball
movement leading to an excellent spacing
and James a chance for a three-point one
high turnovers and some poor defense
games pulls up inside the paint knocks
down another is the shot clock runs out
which is allowing would allow the Cavs
to get it going in Trenton Tatum misses
Horford right there to clean it up a
bank at home the basket goes back up
bank shot missed it tips of the veins
Bay's black bile oh what a play by Kevin
low yeah good offensive rebound by
Horford and then a second one it takes
those it back out he's gonna throw the
backcourt Taylor comes up with it one
man to beat exchange and he lays it in
off the glass
how about on the oven out working
everybody on the floor Tatum chasing
down the loose ball not giving up an
inch ability to finish in transition
Celtics rolling into the third I thought
he would come back in to start the
fourth Marcus smart from downtown
[Applause]
Kyle Korver's comes off the screen and
nails the three-pointer more per second
three more is the rebound outlet for
Rose here Terry Rozier throws it down
offer what the slam is it to with some
nice defense Novoselic cross-court to
Tatum has to put it up fires and there's
the exclamation point Boston Celtics
with another dominant win here of these
Eastern Conference Finals and the
Celtics show one win away from a trip to
the NBA Finals